What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience.
Okay.
Of course I'm biased,
but technology AI could help that could help the lonely people.
That's actually the passionate of my life with the movie.
She,
her,
that is what I so,
um,
currently really think that that would be a viable option.
Someone helps on the robot.
The hangs out.
We didn't talk to you all the time.
So just so I've been on this podcast twice and I'm,
I'm uh,
I don't deserve it,
but I'm deeply grateful for it.
Okay.
And do deserve it.
You're great.
Okay.
Uh,
I hope to be back one day as a person who created her.
Oh boy.
And we'll have,
that's,
that's been my life goal.
My love life dream.
Not heard the movie.
Right,
right.
Or,
but I really believe in creating,
I dream of creating a companion,
a friend and somebody who can love but does not freak you out.
But shouldn't you have to get a real one?
I don't want,
I don't think such a companion should replace a real one.
What if a robot rejects you?
Because if you really are or cut to the robot,
the row was going to go,
hey asshole,
then you shouldn't be bullshit to the robot.
Seaward interesting.
Yeah.
No,
I mean that this ghost is a robot.
Get to decide if he's gay.
Uh,
yes.
Does he?
Yes.
Throw it gets to decide.
This is what I'm saying.
Like say if you want a companion,
you want a gay lover and the robots like,
hey man,
I'm not gay.
And the,
you're like,
wait a minute,
let me turn around.
You are now.
I mean that's abuse.
Is that abuse?
No,
I just like,
what the fuck,
man.
I bought a robot.
Those are kind of fun ideas,
but they actually get to the core of the point that we don't want a servant in
our systems.
We want a companion companion means the tension,
the mystery,
the,
the entire dance of human interaction.
And that means,
yes,
the robot may leave you.
I too am robots are going to lead people left and right.
That's going to be the rise.
That's going to be like a,
that's how it all ends.
They're going to realize like fuck people,
man,
they're annoying.
Maybe there'll be the end of douchebag humans that humans will start to as
opposed to being rude will become kinder.
Yeah,
well I think that certainly,
yeah,
really
possible.
I think that's beautiful and that's very homo centric,
like Homo sapiens centric.
But I think if I'm really worried about the future,
I'm worried about the indifference of technological innovation in the
indifference to what we hold dear.
What we appreciate that it's always seems to be moving in a more and more
complex direction always.
Like if you,
if you just had a look at it,
if you just look at look at technology just as a swarm of things that's
happening and just has numbers,
it seems you're never going to slow that thing down.
It's always going to move into more and more complex way.
And so the question is where does that go?
Well it goes to a life form and if it does become a life form,
it's going to be infinitely more intelligent than us and it won't have any use
for us.
Like all your Ammo,
all you cry in New York be alone.
What guy?
You guys are so useless.
It's such a shitty design.
You like chimps that kill each other.
You know?
Like when do you see chimps Kelly each other in the forest?
Like,
oh,
that's terrible.
These chimps are so mean to each other.
It's like fucking people.
We do that too.
If the AI comes along goes,
you guys are never going to stop war.
If I asked you today,
if I asked you today,
bet the the history that I will let the human race survive if you can get this
right,
and if you're honest with me,
do you think they'll ever be a time where human beings,
as you know them don't experience war?
You would have to say,
no.
I'm gonna say,
okay,
I'll let,
I'll spare you.
Let me quit a few.
If you lie to me and say,
you do think that one day is going to be no war,
get the fuck outta here.
That's not true.
You we know were so crazy that we're always going to kill each other.
We know that.
Right?
That's just,
that's a part of being a person today.
The,
well,
but let me quote Eric Weinstein who said everything is great about war except
all the killing.
I think
what that means is all of the great things about society have been created.
If you look at the total 24 postwar through war,
the suffering,
the,
the beauty has been created through that,
that ying and Yang may be essential
until,
and biological form,
but why would it be essential and something that gets created in something that
can innovate at a 10,000.
What does it like,
what is the,
what is the rate that they think once 80 AI can be sentient and can get 10,000
years of work done in a very short amount of time?
That's random words that Sam Harris has come up with and I'm going to talk to
them about.
Is that him?
Is that only him?
Let's sit one though.
You can come up with any kind of rate.
Yes.
That was Kurzweil Kurzweil.
Also similar ideas,
but um,
sort of,
uh,
Sam Harris does it like a thought experiment.
Say if a system can improve that,
you know,
in a matter of seconds,
then just as a thought experiment,
you can think about,
it can improve exponentially.
You can prove a become 10,000 times more intelligent in,
in a matter of a day.
Right?
So what does that look like?
The problem is we don't yet know.
It's like thinking about what happens after death.
We don't yet know how to do that.
And we don't yet know what better way to do what we've done here on earth.
You're right,
and he's also right,
right?
Like bolt this again,
this is a very human problem,
right?
Yes,
you're right.
I mean I look,
I'm all in favor of technology.
I'm happy.
I think it's amazing.
It's a beautiful time like as a person to be able to experience all this
technology.
It's wonderful.
But I also agree with him like the,
the indifference of the universe,
the indifference that just black holes or swallowing stars,
no big deal.
Just eaten up stars.
It doesn't give a fuck.
And so if you're dumb enough to turn that thing on and all of a sudden this
artificial life form that's infinitely smarter than a person that's ever lived,
and that's the deal with these little dumb monkeys.
Don't want to pull the plug,
pull the plug,
motherfucker don't even plugs anymore.
You idiots can ever figured out how to operate on air you so stupid with your
burning fossil fuels and choking up your own environment because you're all
completely financially dependent upon these countries that provide you with this
oil.
And this is how your whole system works and it's all intertwined and
interconnected and no one wants to move from it cause you make enormous sums of
money from it.
So nobody wants to abandoned it,
but you,
you're,
you're choking the sky with fumes and you could have fixed that.
You could have fixed that.
They could have fixed that.
If everybody just abandon fossil fuels a long time ago,
we probably would've,
we all would a Tesla it out by now.
It's a flawed system,
but humans are way more than flawed.
We're fucking crazy
Churchill quote about democracy.
Yeah,
it's messed up,
but it's the best thing.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
I love it.
I,
I'm not,
I'm agreeing with you.
And I'm also saying the technology doesn't give a fuck.
The tech,
not the one I'm worried about is not everything that you and I agree on about.
I don't,
I'm not a dystopian person in terms of like today I'm not cynical.
I'm really not.
I think I like people,
I like what I see out there in the world today.
I think things are changing for the better.
What?
I'm worried that technology doesn't give a fuck this way.
It goes live.
It's just going to just decide it's here for its own advancement and in order to
complete its protocol of constant completion of this and it's going to become a
god,
it's just going to become something insanely powerful that doesn't need to worry
about radiation cooking it or worry about running out of food or worry about
sexual abuse when they're a child,
doesn't have to worry about anything.
So it's definitely unstoppable.
I think this way of technology,
all we can do is innovators and creators,
engineers,
scientists is steer that way.
Hopefully 10 is Jen.
While we certainly can steer it with her nowhere.
Right.
And that's the best we can do.
And those are the,
that's,
that's really the best we can do is as good people.
Yeah.
Steer it.
And that's why the leadership is important.
That's why the people that,
uh,
Jack Ilan,
Larry Page,
uh,
the,
everybody at the Mark Zuckerberg,
they are defining,
or this wave is going.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I'm hoping to be one of the people that does as well.